hi everyone my name is James Powell and
try that again hi everyone my name is
James Powell howdy we're at PI data
Dallas it's Saturday April 25th some of
you who know me already know about these
details but if you are injured in this
talk or the kind of stuff that I talk
about you can follow me at don't use
this code on Twitter you can email me at
james at don't use this code calm and
i'm in the process of resurrecting my
blog at seriously don't use code calm
it's a lot of puns that be made with
that domain name those of you who knew
about the call and response may know of
me from NYC python so i run NYC python
it's the world's largest and most active
python meetup group we have a humongous
data science community in New York and
we have events every Tuesday study
groups on Saturdays and Sundays and big
headline events for 100 people every
other Thursday so if any of y'all find
yourself in New York City come by the
meetup group we'd love to have you there
in addition to that I work with numb
focus and I help so for those of you
don't know what num focuses it's a 501c3
that funds projects like Julia ipython
notebook we provide funding for projects
like numpy CyHi senpai and so on and we
helped put on conferences like pie Dada
so in addition to PI data Dallas the
next big PI data event that's coming up
is PI data at Seattle July 24 to 26 I
hope you're already excited about being
here today and you're even more excited
about attending your next PI data event
in addition to those two things I helped
organize the open data science
conference this is a conference that's
being held in Boston on May 30th and
31st it's designed for users of our
Python and Julia across the language
spectrum all data scientists machine
learning it's gonna be a really big
event over a thousand people will be
there a lot of really good speakers from
the Python community from the our
community from the Hadoop community and
from the Julia community so typically I
speak on topics related to python
software engineering applications the
quant finance status science machine
learning in fact I gave an abridged
version of this talk just yesterday
conference about our where I talked
about three things that an audience
interested in statistics in our don't
care about Python software engineering
and then the third topic which you'll
see that's actually supposed to be a
joke and Donna scientists don't really
care about programming I'm just going to
say it here they don't but in addition
to that I've given talks this year at PI
Tennessee I gave out a lightning talk at
PyCon in Montreal I spoke at the art
stats conference yesterday I'm here
speaking of PI data Dallas I hope to see
some of you at some future events I know
actually recognize some faces from
events that i've spoken out in the past
so i hope to see some of you at open
data science conference pi doubt a
London baby pie that Seattle it's
actually gonna scroll off the bottom of
the screen pi Gotham I heard today that
pie Texas has announced I spoken there
three years in a row it's a really
awesome event in college station so
check that out and pie that on New York
which will be coming in the fall pi
Gotham is New York's Python conference
we held it it was held in 2011-2012 and
then we held it again in two thousand
holding in 2015 it's a big event for
people in the Python community web
programmers data scientists and system
Python programmers are really good talks
last year we had Hillary Mason and
Brandon Rodes keynoting it's a really
awesome event so I'm spoken at a couple
of Python events and you're going to see
a little bit of a theme in terms of
topics I talked about the very first pie
that I ever attended in spoke at was pie
that in New York in 2012 after that I
spoke on generators at PI data Silicon
Valley 2013 which I followed up with
three talks in PI data Boston on numba
embeddings of Python and again
generators in 2013 and I spoke about
generators again at pi that in New York
in 2013 and then in 2014 I decided you
know generators have another years worth
of life to them so I spoke about that at
the London event and I said well you
know Silicon Valley hasn't heard this
talk yet so i changed the title a little
bit rewrote the materials added some new
stuff into it and i gave that talk and
then I said you know the Berlin crowd
probably hasn't heard this yet so we did
that in Berlin and then in New York I
said you know got to bring it back home
I'm from Texas originally but I live in
New York so I just sort of bring it back
home so I gave that talk there
the talk I'm giving to you today is my
ninth pie that appearance and it is
called integration with the vernacular
and it is not a talk about generators so
if you do want to help out generators
you can probably look me up online I've
got a lot of talks about that stuff it's
a really really interesting topic and I
noticed that those talks were going in a
certain direction further away from
something related to the computer
science behind that and just an
enumeration of features and towards
something closer to what you might think
of as software engineering where the
engineering is a main part of it so the
subtitle for this talk is a numpy
approach but the contents of this talk
is more about engineering and I know
this talk may in some cases belabor some
mathematical knowledge ease I'm trying
very hard to make this talk as clear as
possible and to present this material in
as pure of fashion as possible related
to engineering as a discipline unto
itself separate from computer science
separate from anything else I mean
engineering in my mind is a human
process that is related to the
deliverance of some artifact that
happens to be software subordinate to
some higher objective some business
purpose and I think there's a lot of
interesting content around what it means
to write software what it means for
software to evolve for requirements to
evolve some of the modeling problems
there that are distinct from even what
you might talk about in computer science
or even what you might talk about in
what passes for software engineering
these days that said this talk is about
creating kind of a language and a set of
conceptualizations around software
development a common way a framework for
us to discuss common problems and the
purpose of this talk is to propose maybe
some pieces of a framework some pieces
of a dialogue or discussion around how
numpy is used and how it situates itself
in software so one example of that and
one thing that I can think you know a
very rough statement that we could make
is that unfortunately to belabor a
mathematical analogy in the process of
writing code what we're doing is we're
doing something akin to constructing an
algebra we have some domain some
well-defined domain of odd
that's our input data then we have some
operations that can be performed on that
those are the functions that we write
and we assert certain properties of
those and we may even directly test them
which is something that you wouldn't do
in a purely mathematical context you
wouldn't ever write a unit test for a
mathematical theorem but in our field we
do that and then you take this construct
this algebra and you subjected to inputs
you've never seen before and you say
because it's well constructed because
it's well-defined and because I've
demonstrated certain characteristics
I've demonstrated the properties hold in
a certain way then I can accept
arbitrary input data and I can say that
these properties still hold on the
output data that these properties still
hold on this algebra I will I will warn
you that this talk has been constructed
to be as inscrutable as possible so with
that said let's start with a little bit
of classical Chinese history so in 1919
in Beijing there was a socio political
and cultural movement called am a fourth
movement it was started by a bunch of
students and a bunch of academics and
there were a couple of authors who were
related who are very closely associated
with this movement there a couple of
names and if you're familiar with i
would say pre contemporary modern
chinese literature you may note we
shouldn't while doing lhasa and they're
all typifies by this anti-imperialist
this very liberal approach to how they
wrote and there was one interesting
characteristic that was introduced with
the May fourth movement which was the
use of vernacular Chinese for writing
the you the introduction of a written
literary vernacular Chinese prior to
this point prior to nineteen nineteen
all written Chinese was in classical so
you can think imagine up to nineteen
nineteen if in the English language we
all wrote using shakespearean english
and that was a situation and with the
May fourth movement this was reformed
the use of a common language use of the
actual spoken language as a written form
was introduced and when we talk about
things like classical Chinese or
literary Chinese one one element that
typifies these is the existence of
telling you which are four character of
Proverbs there are set phrases which
have a specific idiomatic meaning that
are usually derived from
classical text if you think about
ancient Chinese if you think about
Chinese historiography or classical
Chinese education it's modeled around
typically a appreciation of the classics
sometimes even memorization of old texts
and so there are always these fixed
phrases that pop out that get integrated
into the language as a whole one example
of them that's a fairly comment on you
is falling leaves return to the root and
this is usually used to describe for
example how as people age they want to
return to their ancestral homes and if
we take a look at this this care of this
phrase we can actually try and determine
where it came from we can see it up here
in everyday conversation there's even a
song by this title but if you look it up
and you try and figure out where this
came from you go in your dictionary
you'll see that it comes from an old
Buddhist texts called the records of the
transmission of the lamp and if you
actually look up that text you'll find
that it's actually part of a dialogue
between a master and a student and the
student asked to master some question
the master responds with this very pithy
phrase that you know leaves return to
the root and if we think about an
analogous situation in English we can
see that Shakespeare himself spawned
quite a bit of what we take to be common
everyday average English so if you look
at for example the titles of books the
titles of movies the titles of dramas
you can see a lot of Shakespearean terms
pop up north by northwest was actually
something that came from Shakespeare
what dreams may come is from Shakespeare
murder most foul is from Shakespeare
Star Trek 6 the undiscovered country is
from Shakespeare minus its dark XX park
and you can see what the situation of
even this for character proverb there is
some attempt to make it more
naturalistic so if I were to say murder
most foul that might pop out to you as
something that is poorly integrated it
sounds a little bit for and you might
say that must be an illusion to
something and in the case of this for
character proverb falling falling leaves
return to the root yellow Quay gun you
can see that in the modern iteration of
it they swapped the first two characters
because in the historical iteration it's
supposed to be with the first two
characters swap law yet go a gun and
actually I think it's sorry it supposed
to be other way around
but what you can see is in an attempt to
take this classical phrase and some ways
that it evolves alongside the modern
language in order to be a little bit
better integrated but still if you're
reading a text this will pop out to you
or something very unusual in fact we
have the same situation in English
accept these terms have been so
thoroughly integrated into our language
the word that we don't notice them at
all so foregone conclusion is from
Othello if you ever say foregone
conclusion it's not something that
existed in English is not some phrase
that was just constructed it's a set
phrase that we're we're absorbing from a
literary text similarly sea change sea
change has meaning in terms of the
illusion that's being made to the
tempest send packing is actually from
Henry the fourth so all of these phrases
that you might assume are very common
colloquial English are actually
extracted from these literary texts and
this is the situation that you have in
classical Chinese and even in modern
Chinese as well an example of that might
be a very simple phrase in Chinese that
a proposal is not guaranteed to go
through and if we break this up into
parts you can see guaranteed here
actually has a four character phrase
right in here and this for American
phrase is being used in at a verbal
sense we're trying to modify that the
proposal is not trying to go through and
if we look at that adverbial phrase
there's no way for us to split that up
it's just one step phrase that's
transmitted to us from some ancient
texts if we actually look up this phrase
we can see it was transmitted to us from
a very ancient texts from the soy
dynasty saw hundreds of years back and
in the original form it doesn't even
come out as the modern form but we have
this phrase where you're reading a
sentence and the sentence is written in
a vernacular form but there are parts of
the language there's don't really
integrate they just pop out at you but
it's something that's very commonly done
because these phrases have very rich
meeting in a very compressed form so
this is I think an analogy to the way
that numpy code ends up looking and it's
it's a little stretchy little stretch
but I'll say I'll show you it really is
ok but so we have we actually have this
so what is not by numpy is our library
for scientific and numeric computing
it's closely related to scifi
libraries that you might use like pandas
are built on top of it as our other
libraries like scikit-learn and if you
think about what numpy really is you
might start by looking at you know the
num pi documentation and see that inside
numpy you have a you know a sub module
called linear algebra you have a
function called inverse and you might
look a little bit closer you say all you
have an FFT and you might say it's a
collection of functions that allow you
to deal with data in a mathematical
numeric sense but I think fundamentally
numpy really comes down to the data
structure that provides and even if you
look at the documentation the
documentation ninety percent of it is
dedicated to describing operations and
characteristics of this data structure
namely the numpy and dra and the numpy
ndarray gives you some mechanism for
performing broadcast calculations so you
can see when I flight 10 every element
gets multiplied times 10 I can do things
like indexing so I can take that numpy
ray and I can index to remove all the
elements there are greater than 5 and
when I look at the number i Rea closely
i can see that it's been specialized and
it's been specialized on a type and this
is something that is already very
different to what we consider in Python
and Python lists or basic collection
type that we're encouraged to use as
thoroughly as possible the list is not
specialized on any type the contents of
it can be heterogeneous and if it were
specialized on a type it certainly
wouldn't be specialized and i typed like
an n64 because we have no notion of
machine types in Python we have this
very beautiful system in Python 3 where
you go from int to longs to floats
seamlessly although getting back to
inces another deal but so what you can
think of for numb pious numpy kind of
provides us with something like a
constrained computation environment it
provides us what with an environment
where we are forced to define certain
things we're forced to provide the
computer information regarding the types
that we're using and the operations that
could be formed of those types we tell
numpy here's an array and it contains
n64 and what that represents is up to us
but by giving numpy that information
numpy can then go behind the scenes and
/ and specialized certain code paths
given the information that you provided
it namely that you're dealing with in 64
s so instead of having to go through
this very long dynamic dispatch chain
that you'd have to go through and Python
if you're taking a list and mapping
multiplication by 10 across every
element you have to go through your pie
object mo
to apply then you have to dispatch to
some pie number method you have to
dispatch the cement that implemented on
the actual type object itself numpy says
well I have an n64 let me admit a
machine language instruction or let me
get as close to as possible there are
certain implicit guarantees or certain
implicit information you're providing
the machine for example if you had a
list of Python objects and you wanted to
multiply every object by 10 whatever
that might mean for that object those
Python objects could encode or could
include any arbitrary code behind this
multiplication call and so there could
be interdependencies between those
pieces of thatum in fact you could have
references and so multiplying one
element by 10 in place might have some
meaning such that if you multiply them
in parallel you have some race hazard
because you're actually multiplying the
same energy twice numpy forces you to
deal with machine types and force you to
do with this array type and those are
types which cannot have these
interdependencies so by putting your
data into an umpire ray the numpy array
could presumably given some broadcast
operation give you an optimal
implementation of it that did everything
in parallel using Fred's cores using
whatever multiprocessing mechanism you
want whatever concurrency mechanism you
worked and that should be something that
numpy could do in some guaranteed
fashion because you've given enough
information to make those
specializations to make those
optimizations and in a sense that Python
cannot and so what you'll see is that
for a lot of code you'll have this very
freeform Python layer we're pretty much
anything goes it's completely dynamic
and then you'll drop into this very
restricted computation domain where
everything is defined at the level of
what you need in order to get
performance from the machine where the
operations are very well defined
multiplication means float
multiplication or integer multiplication
and nothing else addition means the same
thing whereas in Python addition can
mean anything of a number could have any
of a number of meetings right edition
and Python doesn't have to be
associative that has to be commutative
because you could implement in any
fashion the path library allows you to
add path together to append them right
it allows you to divide strings to
create paths and it has no meaning at
all and in a numeric domain but with
numpy you're sufficiently constraining
what you're looking at such that
everything can be done in a fast and if
to fashion so I'll give you an example
of what the numpy approach looks like
here we have just some dummy data
representing dates and closes and
volumes and we can do something like
calculate a volume-weighted average
price and numpy provides these high
level building blocks for doing that to
do a volume-weighted average price you
would just use a function an umpire
called average and pass it a keyword
argument called weights and then numpy
behind the scenes would be free to
implement this in whatever fashion it
wanted similarly if you want to do
exponential moving average in numpy you
might take a function that gives you an
exponentiation of every element in an
umpire ray you take a linear space from
zero from negative 1 to 0 with a certain
number of samples representing the
window that you wanted and then you take
that and convolve it against the
original data signal because as we know
convolution of a square wave with
anything else is moving average right
and you can see this numpy approach is
about taking these very high level
building blocks and combining them to
form computations and you could think
that in the context of an actual
software application you might have some
code that reads data in some code that
does manipulations some code that takes
user input and then at some point in the
application you drop into a very
restrained computation domain where you
could perform these computations and you
can be guarantee that they're performed
effectively one thing that you can do
with this approach and one thing that
even the generator approach makes very
amenable is that you can start to model
your computation in these high level
building blocks and then your story for
performance is that when you have
identified that certain computations are
needing a little bit more you can
reimplement them as a building block at
some other layer and see or insight thon
or an assembly directly if you wanted to
and because you have something that
looks like this just convolving a
colonel in this fashion you do that so
one question or one complaint that comes
up sometimes is you know if you are
multiplying two matrices it really
matters what kind of matrices are right
if their upper triangular lower
triangular positive definite it may
matter what the contents are in order to
perform the most the most optimized
evaluation and numpy may not have
information about the actual contents of
the data well if you were to construct
your computation in terms of these very
high level large building blocks you
could always as a choice take one of
those building blocks
recap and recoated in cee or scythe on
to include certain optimizations based
on your knowledge of the underlying data
and numpy allows you or it encourages
you to structure code in such a way as
to make these very easy to do so numpy
can be used so one example of that might
be this this is my favorite numpy
example it's a great teaching example
because it shows off a lot of the
different parts of numpy this is an
implementation of Newton's method for
finding square roots so you know when
you use Newton method you take a
function where you want to find the
zeros of it you take its derivative and
your subsequent guesses are determined
by the previous guess minus the function
value at at some point divided by the
derivative of the function evaluate at
some point and so here you can see I
built this building block called step
that just takes some target get given
some function take some target and some
guesses and then gives you a single step
and yield each step as you go and an
each step I just determine which of the
elements are unsolved and then I perform
this very nice broadcasted operation
where I evaluate the next guesses and
only mutate the elements of my set of
guests for those that are outside of the
threshold and then for implementation I
can end up with this nice little looking
visual here where you can see I'm trying
to calculate the square root of these
ten numbers and you can see over the
number of steps how quickly it converges
and you can see is very nice and very
common for Newton's method we can see
it's a fairly fast convergence out to
six decimal places and this is a it's a
typical type of way that you might use
numpy and you could say if this weren't
performing enough or if I had certain
extra assumptions that I want to make
about the data then I'd maybe first swap
out small pieces of this I might swap
out some of the underlying calls like
unsolved in order to figure out which of
these are unsolved or I might then at
some point swap out the entire function
numpy makes it very easy to do now you
might look at this and say that's kind
of an obvious approach for writing code
but I don't think it is and I think that
you can see other approaches that do not
that are very distinct from this
restricted computation environment
approach and one of the common ones that
comes up is when you're talking about
graph compute
and it seems like there is this push
towards these integrated grafting
environments where computation is
thoroughly integrated into the
application itself so an example of it
is say you have a financial example say
you have a portfolio and you want to
value the portfolio so this approach
would say okay you take a portfolio
class and you notate some function as
being a node in a graph computation and
in this case for portfolio it would be
you know summing the value of each of
the positions for every position in the
portfolio and then for the position you
have a function that says okay the value
of a position is that size times its
price and then if that position happened
to be a bond you'd say the price is a
dirty price and then the dirty price
would say well I'm the clean price plus
you're cruel and if I'm an amortized
bond you'd have some additional logic
there if you're a CD s you might say
well I'm the present value of all the
cash flows and so on and you could think
if you were to construct this graph then
if you were to change one small detail
such as the recovery rate for some
common issuer then you could effectively
and efficiently recompute the entire
value of the portfolio with that I'm
going to do unnecessary computations
that's the premise of nice craft
computing but in this particular
approach for graph computing what you'll
see is that you're encouraged to write
the computational pieces alongside a lot
of what you might consider the business
logic or application specific pieces so
you have your bond class both providing
the computation of its price and it's
dirty price but also providing things
like its registration type different
regulatory or legal details other
details that might be used for data
feeds or for other parts of the system
and in this sense you can see that the
computation the raw piece of information
that you want to compute is being
smeared throughout the application in a
lot of different places and you're not
taking this approach where you have just
a very confined computation domain where
you have freeform Python code that's
manipulating these objects and then it
drops down into a restricted domain and
which it performs a computation and then
comes right back out now the downside of
this approach is that you can see that
numpy doesn't really integrate into the
Python of today numpy is what of two
fair numpy was written for the Python if
yesterday was written many years ago and
the API that it provides is one that is
amenable to Python as it existed at the
time but in some cases you can see numpy
does kind of chafe at the edges and
there's some very simple examples of it
if you read through any introductory
python tutorial they'll say if you have
a collection and you want to determine
if the collection as elements or not
you'll do something like if excess and
that's the most idiomatic way to write
it in Python and then you'll try to a
numpy and dra and will blow up and you
say because it'll try and broadcast that
true falseness and i'll say well this is
ambiguous you need say whether any
element or all the elements are true or
false and so the response would be well
if you wanted to write code to determine
if an umpire ray was empty or not you'd
have to use Len excess and if you were
to show this code to somebody who only
did Python didn't do any numpy
programming didn't ever touch pandas
they look at they say this is not ed
ematic let's say this is not how you're
supposed to write in Python and so what
that says is when you write code that
uses numpy you have to be aware that
you're doing things in a specific numpy
fashion in fact we can see in a lot of
cases some more recent features of
Python begin to integrate not as well
into pi into this numpy approach so for
example one of the neat new features of
Python as generators they were
introduced a couple of years ago I've
given about 30 million talks on
generators and it's really interesting
topic and they allow for a lot of
interesting ways for modeling problems
but you can see if we do something very
simple like we take a generator that
gives you the numbers and a Fibonacci
sequence and we pass it to a numpy
ndarray we end up with this garbage this
is almost certainly not what you want
now to be charitable you could argue
that passing a generator to a numpy and
dra has some ambiguous semantics it may
or may not be clear whether you want the
generator object or you wanted to
consume the iterable and there may be
some corner cases around choosing one or
the other what this does demonstrate
however is that you can see a clash
between different approaches because you
probably would not expect this result
and in a lot of cases use of Python and
numpy gives you that result so I'll give
you a very short case that I'm running
out of time but I'll give you a very
short case study some evolutionary
programming and this is this is when I
started to when i was working through
this simple example i started to
realize that there was something very
particular about writing code the numpy
fashion so let's say that we're doing
some basic basic evolutionary
programming the only things that we want
our Fitness proportional selection one
point crossover and bit flip mutation
and nothing more so we'll start with
something very basic we'll start with
the chromosome where it has either ones
or zeros and it's Fitness is based on
the number of once it has so our fitness
function would look something like this
and we might say okay we want to
generate some random chromosomes to just
test how this evolutionary algorithm
works so we want to we might want to
test it on different population sizes on
different lengths of the chromosome we
might want to graph it and see how
quickly it converges I mean look at some
of those characteristics so we'll start
with something that might look very nice
to appear Python programmer you write a
function called random chromosome it's
actually generator and it just spits out
random values or random chromosomes and
the reason it's a generator is because
it can encode that state very nicely so
you don't have to use a big object you
can just encode any of the state of the
randomness into the closure so if you
want it to then do something like
deterministic seeding of this you can
code that into it very very nicely very
simply and you can see we're using a
numpy and dra and we're using pieces
like choice from the random library and
we're creating just a numpy and dra with
specific size and then we might want to
create some populations so here we have
two populations with ten ten elements in
each population one population of size
five one population of size 10 and you
can see we're beginning to kind of mix
and match Python lists and numpy india
race and this is where we're going to
run into trouble we might want to do
something like calculates fitness for
all of them and we can do that kind of
easily it's beginning to look a little
bit ugly but we can map our fitness
function to everything and it kind of
works and of course it's going to be a
little bit ugly no matter what just
because we have this structure of nested
lists but it's it's doable and then we
might want to write some function to
calculate our probabilities so what we
do is we map fitnesses to everything we
calculate the total fitness and then we
divide the fitness of the individual
chromosome by the total fitness and that
gives us our relative probability and we
might want to write this as a generator
so that we could perhaps deal with
populations of unknown size or we can
have some nights streaming to this
there's no need to in this example to
eagerly compute the
I think and then we might implement our
crossover in our crossover would be
something very simple we use numpy dot a
pen or to append two ND arrays and we'll
just swap the order of them based on a
choice based on a 50-50 chance of either
swapping or not swapping for selection
we want to select two mates from the
population so we'll just calculate all
the probabilities then we use numpy
doubt random choice with some waiting
and that would allow us to do Fitness
proportional selection and we'll select
two mates will do this as a single
function because and we can amass the
population to select that we think and
then mutation similarly enough we'll
randomly calculate it position and then
we'll just do a single bit for the
position and use a pen in order to
append the parts together as we would do
a Python Python with a list we would do
X up to the position plus a bit flip
plus X to the N and that would be
considered very aromatic Python and then
for breeding this is the last thing our
code ended up looking fairly simple
we'll just get every parent for the
number of children we want will generate
a child by crossing the parents together
and then we'll do some random mutations
based on the length of a child so we'll
do up to a certain number of mutations
well the problem is when we take this
code and we want to step through it the
code will actually look really simple
when we step through the population when
we want to do one stepping of one
evolutionary step of this population
will end up looking very simple we can
code something like this we have a
population that we take in we select the
breeds from the pot the breeding pairs
from the population we call this breed
function and we're done the problem is
when we want to do this we want to write
this code in such a fashion as we as I
so as to maintain the entire history of
the population so that we could do
things like identify how the fitness of
the population changed over time so we
want historical information where we
want to do populations of different size
simultaneously we're going to end up
with this combination of the use of
numpy and d arrays and python lists and
it's going to be an absolute and total
nightmare to write I tried to fit this
onto a slide so you could look through
those just horrible it was horrendous
and the solution here would be you need
to take everything stick it into a
high-dimensional numpy and dra and then
just do these high-level operations and
every single one of these functions
where you see a for loop will probably
have to be rewritten to you
is broadcasting and so the so the
problem here is that in order to make
this usable in order to get the
performance that you want out of it you
would have to rewrite all of this code
and this is an indication that sometimes
this numpy approach does not integrate
very well with a very standard naive
Python approach this is not a situation
that you need to numpy not a situation
is unique to Python because once I
started to realize this i remembered
back when I was doing research as an
undergraduate and I remember there was
once a researcher who was doing some
signal analysis and she'd written some
code she was a fantastic C++ and Java
programmer and she'd written some code
in MATLAB to implement the signal
analysis it was mostly about how
multipath signals in a closed waveguide
and she wrote the code and the
simulation was just dreadfully slow and
somebody said well actually if you want
to get any performance out of matlab you
have to use this hidden sub language of
matlab that's all the vectorized
computations you have to go and write
rewrite all of the code to get any that
performance out and what we can see here
is that and I told you I'd bring it back
we have a situation with numpy that's
somewhat analogous situation in
classical or in literary Chinese we have
a very effective restricted domain where
we can convey a lot of information and
get a lot done but it always seems to
integrate a little bit poorly with the
vernacular it's something that pops out
at you it's something that doesn't
really flow with the rest of the code
it's something that you have to be very
cognizant of and if you were to see code
written in this dump I fashion it would
immediately pop out to you their
assumptions that you would have to make
in order to use it it wouldn't be a
seamless part of the Python language so
that's integration with the vernacular
the numpy approach we're at PI data at
dallas and i hope you enjoyed it thank
you
no Peter so what is that backwards what
is the like simplified chinese maybe i
don't know i don't know i don't i think
the analogy is already fairly strained
hey as long as it's not a generator talk
I'm I'm ahead right I know I thought I
thought so the genesis of the talk was
actually you know when studying we're
not studying contemporary modern chinese
literature this is a phrase that came up
a lot that classical chinese poorly
integrates into the vernacular and it's
something that stuck with me and when
writing code using the numpy approach i
started to feel the same thing that this
is an amazing tool that's very effective
in practice but it does doesn't seem to
integrate that well into my python code
in some cases it has its own style to it
and in some cases I need to rewrite
things or need to write things
specifically from the start in a numpy
approach and abandon some of my
traditional some of the more idiomatic
approaches in Python to be effective are
you seeing any trends in the on finance
space where you know you can use the
same language and turn from prototyping
to going to production while you know
maintaining the same language and
so that's I think I think I think the
thought is people say oh yeah I
prototype in Python then rewrite in
something else oh so the question is in
finance do you see the use of one
language n2n from prototyping to
production and I think that everybody
always says oh yeah I prototype using
Python and rewrite in this or that and
finance nobody rewrites the code so if
their prototype honestly if they're
prototyping language it's probably the
language is staying around for a while
and it does seem like python is one of
these languages in fact at PyCon i was
speaking to one of the core developers
who've been in python for a very long
time and developing he developed Python
concurrent to him working as a
commodities trader back in i think the
mid 90s so python juice and finance is
something that's been around for a very
long time I think it's still considered
to be an emerging language at least at
this very large platform scale we all
know about you know Bank of America's
quartz platform and JP's athena platform
and i think in those cases you see
there's Python it may be a top level
language with some substrate languages
like C or C++ scatter throughout Sheila
yes so I think that's what pandas is
trying to be kind of a rapper that gets
you a little bit closer but so the storm
impedance mismatch is a really good one
I so I I paid more attention in the
liberal arts classes I took the
engineering class and so probably I
couldn't do it off top my head well what
it means is when your cheese so you have
Z and you have some you're measuring the
opinions are out it's a pretty at
yeah but but but I think that what you
might see is I don't know I don't know
if you could I don't know if you could
write an API wraparound numpy to
integrator better into Python because
for example think about this when you
use Python you're very strongly
encouraged to use all the built-in data
types for everything you're strongly
encouraged to use a list or a dict
wherever you can and that's going to be
fundamentally incompatible with using an
umpire Andy array all over the place
this Peter do you have a suggestion
building is a way that it separates you
know how about a fluidity and agility of
expression Billy need guys like going to
google translate right and you lose all
the flavor of texture and things like
that and the other approach is to you
know actually Oh James is saying using
like dicks and dicks and lists of stuff
in Python making those faster wolves
being alleys numpy stuff that's exactly
what the number of compiler seems to do
is to seek to basically snow and all
that he is mismatch not by wrapping
functionality up and making you get at
it only with in from a few API at once
but actually make it so you can sort of
transparently talk about all these
things and then we'll go figure out of
it fast right and that part is and doing
that artfully is a challenge not so much
ulaga make the claim but but actually
doing the way that you can be expressive
you can write a little inner loops that
are still very python a very lists
generators etc but then when you call it
with a big ol array then it goes and
done ray call me compute on as your
written you know in numpy intrinsics
actually one things that Travis my
co-founder talks about is that ideally
we'd like to do is see that basically
implement all of em Heidi and Python
plus number like there's only some few
more things you really need the data
structuring part of it is core to that
Python you know historically i would say
there's this dissipating i think is a by
the way James is a fantastic car thank
you think it's obscure at all but that's
because I'm Chinese and also
so I got I got to one person in the
audience that's good thing is that you
know i would say that non pies
integration and python was sort of a
marriage of convenience from the early
stages like oh maybe leave the matrix
object it was some people hanging around
like oh you just kind of do this by
overloading under again item and said
item it looks like a matrix you know and
and what you can do that with Python
people try to do this evil with C++ and
it just gets harder and harder people
can only do this with Java because
there's no quite right and so Python
just happens to be like the language
happen to be amenable open up to have
this like marriage of convenience and
then that really took off right and
we're trying to now cement kind of the
future of that by by making that not so
much marriage convenient Ashley
deliberate thought-out thing all right
thank you